tonight the Biden White House is adrift
listen to this according to NBC News Joe
is now hemorrhaging support from
Hispanic Americans African-American
Suburban moms and of course young people
and quote amid a rolling series of
calamities and sinking approval ratings
the president's feeling lately that he
just can't catch a break or Joe Biden
he's just not getting the respect that
he thinks he deserves now naturally he's
now looking for someone to blame so he's
Putin there's always Fox News Hannity
Trump whatever but predictably he
shamelessly now is using the horrific
shooting in Uvalde for political gain
now no doubt there are serious concerns
surrounding this massacre in Texas the
Uvalde School District police chief has
stopped cooperating with the Texas
Department of Public safety's
investigation that can happen that is
incredibly troubling and should be to
everybody make no mistake there is
absolutely zero excuse for the hour plus
us that it reportedly now took law
enforcement to storm that building and
rescue those kids that is their job
there's no reason this country cannot
secure every single school with
well-trained and prepared armed guards
including retired cops retired military
personnel along with metal detectors and
a single point of entry into every
school now Joe Biden is not addressing
any of this instead he's what well
predictably vilifying the Second
Amendment and responsible lawful gun
owners everywhere even threatening to
ban nine millimeter handguns really Joe
take a look
22 caliber bullets will lodging along
and we can probably get it out we may be
able to save the life
a nine millimeter bullet blows the lung
out of the body
so the idea these High Caliber weapon is
uh it is simply no rational cases for it
in terms of what this is about
self-protection hunting I mean I just I
remember the Constitution the second
amendment was never absolute
couldn't buy a cannon when the second
amendment was back
by the way that was debunked but that's
a different issue for a different day
Joe before you rip up that document
called the Constitution what about we
offer school children our precious
children our national treasure the same
exact protection that you Joe Biden
enjoy and all the other high-ranking
politicians enjoy and Hollywood stars
and joy that's armed security and by the
way absolutely nothing Biden said is
true not a word uh what will we the
people be totally defenseless what do we
do when evil people break into our homes
how did that defund dismantle no bail
stuff work out so far in this country
now disarming every law-abiding citizen
no that's not the answer that is a
prescription for chaos death and
destruction and the American people
won't tolerate it and nor should they
and keep in mind according to one study
cited by the almighty CDC of all people
there are up to two and a half million
defensive gun uses each year meaning
saving lives another study found there
are at least 2.1 million defensive gun
uses annually that means the guns that
Joe Biden just demonized are used more
for self-defense and for criminal acts
and according to a multi-year study from
John Lott remember he wrote more guns
less crime well the states with the
largest increases in gun ownership they
also have the largest drop in violent
crimes coincidence I don't think so of
course Joe Biden doesn't care about the
facts he's looking for a political win
uh whatever happened to follow the
science or in this case follow the
statistics after all Biden cared so
deeply about gun violence where's he
been the past 15 years because take a
look at your screen you know since what
2019 at least 4
642 kids in this country have been shot
and killed now all of these lives are
precious again our national treasure
many of these kids were murdered in
Chicago we have been scrolling their
names that you never hear about since
2009 Joe Biden hasn't mentioned their
names once not one single time when he
was vice president for eight years all
those years 500 years in the Senate he
never mentioned it and this weekend
guess what another 47 people shot nine
killed in the windy city and Baltimore
four were killed during a spree of
shootings in New York City three more
were murdered and all told more than 130
people were shot and killed across this
country just this weekend alone in fact
last week's tragedy in Texas there have
been at least another uh there have been
at least 15 other incidents that could
be classified as mass shootings with at
least four victims Joe Biden rarely if
ever mentions any of these acts of
violence why is that because it does not
help him politically sadly much of the
violence that we're talking about is
occurring in America's big blue
Democratic cities in those Deep Blue
Democratic states where those big
liberal socialist Democrats have ruled
with impunity for nearly a hundred years
all of these cities for the most part
they have strict gun control laws and
the violence is only getting worse and
hardly a peep out of any prominent
Democrat instead they cling to groups
like BLM black lives matter the group
that chanted what do we want Dead Cops
when do we want them now and thanks to
the defund dismantle movement Nobel
movement these cities are in tatters
police budgets slashed police
departments vilified in say no bail laws
and a refusal to even prosecute violent
repeat offenders but Joe Biden you know
dare speak out against the radical left
he doesn't have the courage he doesn't
have the commitment to Law and Order and
Safety and Security for any American
which by the way would be the
fundamental prerequisite if we want to
have the ability in this country to
pursue happiness life liberty in the
pursuit of happiness and he also can't
tout any of his accomplishments well he
can't run on that because there are none
Afghanistan war in Europe inflation
stagflation recession coming gas prices
another record today a border crisis and
oh yeah a million covet deaths under
Biden's watch he said he would end the
virus didn't happen so now Biden's
midterm strategy is what a heavy dose of
fear-mongering surrounding banning guns
whipping up the Democratic radical base
Roe v Wade if in fact that is sent back
to the States it will not result in
abortions becoming illegal in America
they'll demagogue that but don't expect
him to offer any real solutions you know
the self-proclaimed you know the guy
that said he was The Great uniter Well
he won't even attempt to work with
Republicans instead he'll vilify them
like always Biden cares more about being
popular in his own party and
capitulating to the radical climate
alarmist religious cult than actually
making the country a better and safer
Place hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else